megan stokes is training to style afro
hair
it's her first week as an apprentice at
this manchester-based salon
with afro hair we would obviously have
to detangle it all
comb it out wherever with straight hair
like this it's just
simply brushing it but then obviously
with all the different hair
types you've got to do different
techniques the training hairdressers
like megan get
is changing a shake-up in national
standards means new hairdressers will
now have to learn to work with all hair
types
including afro and textured hair as part
of their training
customers here told us the gap between
professional knowledge and hairdressing
services
has left some people out of many
that your salons is not european it's
a bit of a nightmare our parents used to
teach us how to eat uh how to do hair
so and in terms of maintaining um hair
we used to just
you know pla doll's hair now you have to
be quite selective to be quite honest
my my recent hairdressers did close down
so i had to kind of venture out
dion smith is part of a programme to
provide free masterclasses across the
country
to help trainees get up to speed what
we're offering is just the fundamentals
like
what is natural hair what are the
different types well how do you
where do you put yourself because
obviously textured hair comes in so many
different types curl patterns
so it's like okay how do i understand
what type of hair i'm dealing with
and what we've been doing is targeting
people that have never sort of dealt
with textured hair
touched it felt it people are just
scared of it i'll put some
cream in there just to grease it gives
it that nice yeah
malika lawrence has been cutting and
styling here for two decades
because manchester's such a diverse city
and the uk as well you know so it's
fantastic that people are not going to
be segregated or
turned away from an establishment simply
because of the hair type
the standards don't just apply to
hairdressing but also beauty therapy
well-being and holistic therapies
they'll all now have to take an
inclusive approach with clients when it
comes to things like race and gender
physical and mental health meeting the
needs of the uk's diverse community
in one standard satya chowdhury sky news
in manchester